this though and speak to Gregory
Campbell he's a democratic unionist
Member of Parliament joins us now live
from Belfast good to have you with us so
first of all does it seem now that it's
it's inevitable that there's going to be
elections in December
well I wouldn't say it's completely
inevitable but it's certainly working in
that direction
um despite all the evidence to the
contrary that sometimes there's deep
divisions in Northern Ireland but one
thing that all the political parties are
united on is saying to the British
government look this election will prove
nothing it will result in broadly the
same outcome we have an election just
six months ago not a lot has changed in
that time so you're re-running an
election to produce probably a similar
if not the same result and we will be no
further forward in fact we may have
regressed because people will obviously
become more entrenched in their
positions as people do and they're all
up to a very fractious election
so you don't expect that these elections
are at all going to break the deadlock
where does it leave governing Northern
Ireland
well in a very difficult place is the
short answer I mean just to give your
your listeners and viewers a position in
Northern Ireland it's quite a debated
Society we're 25 years of of murder and
Terror and bombing and that stopped in
the mid-1990s uh what now has happened
over the course of the past 25 almost 30
years is people broadly speaking are
agreed that we only make progress when
both sides of the community the
unionists and the nationalists the
Protestant the Catholic and many people
who don't fall into either category
unless there is a consensus amongst
those divided peoples and their
political Representatives we won't make
progress and that's where the protocol
Falls because there's not a single
unionist who supports the protocol so it
falls by the very definition that the
British government and even the EU have
defined as progress in Northern Ireland
where people have to work together to
make that progress
are you concerned that the disagreement
over the Northern Ireland protocol also
the cost of living crisis in the UK is
making some unionists think the
unthinkable and I I refer here the
reason I'm asking this some of the polls
in August 2022 poll by the Sunday Times
Belfast Telegraph and Lucid talk found
57 of 18 to 24 year olds a majority in
other words would vote for a United
Ireland if a referendum was held today
do polls like that worry you
no because once people start to think
and talk and rationalize what any
departure from the United Kingdom would
mean for example we have a free at the
point of use National Health Service
they don't have that in the Irish
Republic it would cost every single
person in Northern Ireland hundreds and
hundreds of pounds per year each to
provide that National Health Service
they can trade and a lot of the trade is
right and that that is a big incentive
for people is it not
but the majority of our trade is within
our own country in the United Kingdom
the vast majority of trade in fact the
major holiers this week pointed out to a
House of Lords Committee in London that
if the protocol were to be implemented
and full because at the moment it's only
partially implemented if it were to be
implemented in full the entire East-West
relationship of business and commerce
would collapse within 48 hours that's
how you start the protocol is that's why
the EU has to deal with it and come up
with a more rational and sensible
solution that people from both sides of
the community can buy into
all right thanks so much it's been a
pleasure talking to you
thank you